down by two so good looks are Paramount
for them or you still have two timeouts
we don't want to foul here obviously
switch everything Clarkson
backs it away and then he's grabbed from
behind careful now easy easy no no no no
don't do that and good play Dante
divincenzo
Jordan Clarkson was ready to square up
kamenga blocked the shot then he got the
rebound Clarkson was frustrated and he
fouled him very roughly that's a big
time defense though from kamega I mean
keep your cool elect Clarkson get
frustrated look all the counter moves
the Stop and goes He blocks that one
snatches it now Eisen now I'm telling
you right now when they when they go
look at this
the the you don't have to land a punch
or even do anything like that should be
a technical on Clarkson at a minimum and
this is like that that could be a
flagrance job because it's in the head
and neck area so this review is going to
be really interesting Jordan Clarkson is
all the way in the wrong here and then
he squares up and put the bangs up
you whack a guy in the head or neck area
as he does right there that could be
flagrant one and then after this when
you get into this boxing fight mode
that's not a good thing we can come and
get laughing out of it the perfect
reaction
so Mark Davis 25 years in the league
he has been a long time
finals official
thank you
so Mark Davis 174 playoff games 18 NBA
finals games he's a U.S Naval Academy
grad so letter of the law I actually
think that Mega showed a lot of
restraint while divincenzo did a great
thing there he did a great thing there
because
you don't want to fight you don't want
fine suspensions and you don't want to
lose this game but that foul right there
I'm telling you the one angle we have he
whacks them in the side of the head and
neck and I've seen flagrants called for
a lot less than that
and head in neck area
they use up around there and then Steve
is saying that's going to be a flagrant
because of the whack because he was
frustrated he got his shot blocked so
you could have a loose ball foul on
Clarkson you could have a flagrant which
would be free throws plus possession and
I don't know if you're going to assess a
technical for getting into the Sugar Ray
Leonard's dance afterwards you would
think something's coming down for that
the NBA doesn't
like that kind of action
and Kamika just thought it was funny
backed up he wasn't going to entertain
it
foreign
the arm which has got Clarkson upset and
then I don't know what that was all
about and then kamega starts laughing
that's how I would do the same thing if
I was gonna make
laugh at that hey
she got a two-point lead with 24.9 and
this should tilt in the Warriors face
and camenga did a great job moved his
feet
Jordan Clarkson threw everything he
could at him got the stop got the block
got the ball and Jordan Clarkson was
just frustrated
whatever happens Clarkson should get
penalized more and then Jonathan could
make I mean now here's the thing
unnecessary contact
is the flagger one
unnecessary excessive is flagrant too
you could have a flagrant too and an
ejection here and then offsetting tees
for the little histrionics afterwards
that would be big because he's there
closer so Mark Davis is yeah
penalty two has been assessed Jordan
Clarkson for the unnecessary and
excessive contact above the shoulder to
kaminga both kaminga and Beasley have
been assessed technical fouls they
offset Golden State will shoot two free
throws and get the ball free throw line
extended let's go
just explained it nicely so perfect
unnecessary flagrant one unnecessary
excessive flagrant to ejection two free
throws plus the ball and then Beasley
kamenga offsetting tees and no free
throws are shot then that seems right
as Jordan Clarkson gives out the head
so two free throws for kamenga but you
also retain possession of the ball yeah
that's big